hey guys Pete here yesterday I got some
cool tips directly from the farm heroes
super saga developers so I wanted to
share them with you and take a better
look at each one of them we got 10 tips
as you can see from the graphic and
every one of them will come in handy in
different spots while you're moving your
way through the game if you're not
playing farm hero super yet I suggest
you check it out if you like casual
social games it'll be right up your
alley is a sister title of one of the
most popular match 3 games of all time
farm here at saga which means it has a
similar look and mechanics with added
features that are built off all the
stuff you already love if you've never
played farm arrows don't worry the game
is easy to learn and fun right from the
beginning like most level based games
though it does get difficult as you go
and that is where these tips will help
you out so let's get right to it top tip
number 1 when in doubt make a square
match it's likely to be useful later for
emphasis we have 2 exclamation points
here and making a square match is almost
always a good idea Square matches make
super cropsey's which are good for
several reasons and other things Square
matches do is they also clear out a good
bit of space the super cropsey's hold
their number until you collect them
which can speed things up when you want
to complete your goals and making space
gets the other crops he's moving around
which means lots of good stuff can
happen after you make the match in this
short clip
notice how we can't get the blue match
that we need they solve the problem by
making a purple square match to get
pieces moving and also note that since
purple is a collection color isn't a
collection color it adds to the count of
the nearby cropsey's before it's removed
from the board when you make the green
square match we end up collecting our
blue cropsey's as the wind blows them to
fill in the space left on the board and
we get to finish the level
top tip - if one side of the board seems
locked up use when to move it and create
space win levels are the most unique
feature and farm here is super and they
can be a little bit tough to figure out
since the mechanics are brand new this
tip is reminding us that super saga is
different than any other matching games
we're used to because the pieces on
Winnie levels don't fall toward the
bottom they move in the same direction
of the swipe that we use to make the
match in our clip we can see it is a
link when you level right from the
beginning because the leaves blow across
the screen we're trying to move fij of
the squirrel and the acorn together so
we start making matches in between them
at a point at the point there aren't any
other matches that we can make in
between the two items so we can't get
them closer what are we gonna do we're
gonna have to look outside and make
matches on the outside of that blocked
area create space and change things up
eventually this changes the layout
enough so that we can make a purple
square match which charges fidgets up
and we'll talk about that more in a
later tip and he's able to collect the
acorn
which of which accomplishes our roll
top tip three acorns under the leaves
will always be hidden in the same place
for that level this is pretty
straightforward but it's pretty good to
know at the same time when a level has
leaves on the ground you need to clear
them out to find where the acorns are
that you need to collect sometimes this
can take a few tries to figure out and
so whenever you play this one again
they'll be back in the same place in the
clip we find that there's two acorns at
the bottom of the board we could the
level so we can start from the beginning
again and we find that a chain tube to
pay coins in the exact same position we
could keep playing this level all day
long and that they'll still both be
right there
top tip for matching at the bottom of
the board causes more cascades not to
contradict the game designers here but I
need to mention that this tip applies
specifically to non windy boards this is
a good tip for any match three game with
normal gravity and what's cool is that
if you're playing winning levels you can
actually do this go in any direction
once you get the hang of it so in the
clip you can see that we need to remove
flowers from the top of the board by
making a match at the bottom watch how
the pieces help us out as they fall into
place when the colors filling in the
empty space on the board match up the
flowers get hit and we give that other
matches which help in our collection
top tip 5 try to remove rancid cans as
soon as possible rancid the raccoon is
is up to his old tricks and the beat'em
and super saga we have to make matches
next to his cans which he throws on the
board each time we make a match the can
flips up and hits him and if we do this
enough times he'll get knocked down for
the count in our clip you could see
rancid throws those cans on the board
right away and he'll continue to keep
adding them if you don't start knocking
them back when we hit him with one of
the cans you goes down briefly which
makes it easier for us to focus on
completing our goal top tip 6 in general
removing the static item like flowers or
eyes is the best task to start on first
on different levels you run into oyster
flowers which block the board or cut you
off from being able to collect what you
need so getting them out of it out of
the way will speed things up and it'll
help you get the rest of your collection
so you can beat the level in our clip we
have a ton of flowers and in the way on
this particular board and there's no
real room to make any good match watch
as we clear away the flowers and see how
many different options open up this as
fast as we remove also notice this ties
in with tip 4 as the more space we have
the more you know that has a direct
influence on the number of cascades that
we'll see
top tip seven if you don't beat rancid
he'll come back soon after rancid
doesn't stay on the same levels like he
did in the original farm hero saga
instead he pops up on different parts of
the map and you get one chance to beat
him and collect some coin remember you
have to knock him out and complete the
level to get the corner so our clip
become close to knocking him out and
being the liable but we come up a little
bit short
we were thinking oh well you know that
was close and I really want to earn some
coins but when we look at the map again
the level doesn't have the raccoon on it
anymore don't worry after some time you
will you'll see him hanging out on the
map and he'll be at the bottom left
corner of the screen so you'll know that
he's there and that you can try to beat
him again
top tip 8 in show time you'll get three
moves to collect your super cropsey's so
time is super sagas version of hero mode
if you have three moves left you get
three shots to collect as many
collection points as you can and that
will raise your score if you have a lot
of moves left when you finish the level
you get the extra the extra moves will
like earn you some extra super cropsey's
on the floor and if you have less than
three moves you get to still get to go
you only get like if you have two moves
you'll get to take two extra moves and
you get a chance to clean things up in
our clip you can see that we have a lot
of super cropsey's left and don't want
to have all these points left on the
board sometimes you can't find a match
that will match your supers together
directly so you have to be a little
creative and use matches that will cause
big ones to happen at those extra points
can get you an extra star which
translates into extra growth in the
country show top tip 9 you will always
earn a little bit of growth even if you
don't finish the level growth equals
making coins from the country show and
coins of equal boosters you can use for
tough levels in our clip notice that we
didn't finish the level but even though
we didn't we still earn 5 growth points
for our effort
you
top tip 10 making a super crop see next
to a goat or squirrel will make them
power up as we mentioned earlier super
cropsey's are almost always useful they
can make the squirrel reach further with
his tail when you make make them right
and make the match right next to you the
same goes for the goat except he will
actually jump to a useful spot on the
board so in our clip you'll see that we
have some hay up at the top where we can
we can't you have to collect it but we
can't get to it from the main part of
the board by making a super crop see
right next to the goat it powers them up
and he'll jump to the outside square
where he can collect the hay for us it
should be noted that this is the only
way to get to that square so you don't
want to forget this tip
so those are the top 10 tips from the
farm hero saga team at King Studios in
London I hope this video helped to make
them a little easier to understand
please like the video if you found it
useful and subscribe to my channel to
find all the all the farm heroes super
saga level videos that I put out try to
keep them up to date and if you need
help you can always find it there I want
to thank the King team for putting these
tips together and I'll be posting more
helpful videos based on their content in
the near future thanks for watching talk
to you soon